hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown what you need to
know about the controversy surrounding
the michael flynn case
and the unmasking of the president's
former national security adviser
former federal prosecutor and fox news
contributor andy mccarthy
and fox news digital politics reporter
brooke singman joined host
jessica rosenthal to break it down also
fox news sunday host chris wallace
joins host chris foster to discuss the
political debate about reopening states
the democrats proposal for a 3 trillion
stimulus package
and the 2020 presidential race plus
commentary
by fox news correspondent at large
geraldo rivera
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm maria i'm greg gutfeld i'm liz
clayman and this
is the fox news rundown
friday may 15th 2020 i'm jessica
rosenthal
unmasking names an intelligence tool or
trick
if the public sees that the
intelligence community can't be trusted
to wield these towers without
politicizing them or using them
in capricious ways then there's going to
be a very strong argument
that these powers need to be either
repealed or rolled back
i'm chris foster house democrats have a
new coronavirus stimulus bill
republicans call dead on arrival
fox news sunday host chris wallace
agrees the house
democrats the majority there are pushing
a bill which will make a statement but
doesn't have a chance of
passing uh and republicans are saying
let's wait and see
and i'm geraldo rivera i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
this week the acting director of
national intelligence declassified a
list of names
of obama administration officials who
requested the
unmasking of a name in intelligence
documents
after the 2016 election that was when
the trump administration was
ramping up the name that was revealed
was three star general michael flynn
he was serving at the time as then
president-elect trump's national
security adviser
all right these are the seven names that
have been declassified
and this includes vice president biden
cia director john brennan
james comey james clapper at least one
of those conversations we know was with
russia's ambassador
but also at this time there was a
federal investigation into michael flynn
and
the trump campaign over alleged ties to
russia
and election interference since then
though the mueller investigation
concluded a lack of sufficient evidence
to show the campaign coordinated or
conspired with the russian government
last week's release of house
intelligence transcripts of interviews
with some obama administration officials
revealed a similar narrative no clear
evidence of russian collusion
now with the release of the unmaskers
names things have exploded a bit
remember all of this eventually led to
charges against flynn
that he lied to investigators now south
carolina senator lindsey graham wants
hearings
senator rand paul says this was a major
abuse of power and president trump told
fox's maria bartoromo
it's the greatest political crime in
history if i were a democrat
instead of a republican i think
everybody
would have been in jail a long time ago
and i'm talking with 50-year sentences
it is a disgrace what's happened a
former dni james clabber says no it was
not
requests to unmask are pretty common the
binding campaign said in a statement
that these documents had nothing to do
with an fbi investigation
and confirm normal procedure was
followed others note this couldn't
target flynn because when you ask to
unmask
you don't even know who the redacted
name is yet that's the whole point the
term
unmasking is almost not even an official
term in the intelligence
community brook sigmund is fox's digital
politics reporter it's kind of an
unofficial term if you go back to
even interviews with um former obama
officials and house intelligence
interviews they all say what do you mean
by unmasking
so so nobody saw michael flynn's name
and wanted to unmask it but it was a
a u.s citizen speaking to the russian
ambassador
and clearly these officials were
receiving some sort of intelligence that
made them question who this u.s citizen
was
speaking to the russian ambassador
um discussing whatever they were
discussing so
acting dni rick grinnell requested that
the list of these names be declassified
and they were
and these this is a list of officials
who sought to
quote unquote unmask what turned out to
be the identity of michael flynn
so they were seeing this u.s citizen
repeatedly speaking to
the russian ambassador or whoever he was
speaking to
in these intelligence reports and
requesting that the name of this person
be unmasked yeah this was a broad time
frame right this was from november 8th
till january 31st
2016 to 2017. so it wasn't just that
conversa
those conversations michael flynn had
with the russian ambassador this was a
a much more wide ranging time frame
right
sure and and absolutely november 8 2016
so right after the presidential election
right after the uh then candidate trump
becomes president-elect donald trump
through january 31st 2017 which is
which is a week or so after president
trump was
inaugurated and and took office so
there were dozens of requests from
former obama officials some that were
carryovers into the trump administration
um and like james comey for example
who made these requests and there were
obama administration officials including
vice president joe biden
who were making these unmasking requests
right what are we to make of that
if anything at this stage clearly
intelligence documents were coming
before
vice president biden and i am not sure
why he as the vice president would have
need to make an
unmasking request a lot of times i mean
on the other side of this if you're not
in the president's camp president
trump's camp and you are arguing that
i mean a lot of people that are not
necessarily in
president trump's camp are arguing that
this is a very
routine uh national security
intelligence collection tool
with the unmasking process meaning that
you could receive this piece of
intelligence and and really need to
understand who this individual is so you
seek to unmask them in order to fully
get a picture of
of the intelligence so so but we do know
eventually he was
charged right with with lying to
investigators and he did end up you know
pleading guilty as we know
to that that is a direct result
of of of the conversations he was having
with the the russian ambassador the the
very conversations were talking about
it in which officials asked for
unmasking so he
he pleaded guilty to making false
statements to fbi agents in his
interview which took place on january
24th 2017
fbi agents went to the white house uh
then national security adviser michael
flynn did not have
counsel present and he was clearly
questioned
about his communications with the
russian ambassador sergey kislyak
at the time and he made a false
statement
and that is what he was charged with and
a lot of people that are flynn allies
argued that those fbi agents actually
got him in a perjury
trap he didn't have counsel uh they sh
he didn't know they were listening to
his phone calls
those are things that people in flynn's
camp are arguing at this point
brooke one one last thing that now that
we know the justice department wants to
drop this case against
michael flynn but apparently it's not so
easy right i mean the judge in flynn's
case is insisting that
another judge basically argue against
the case being dropped
so it's true judge sullivan who oversees
the flynn case
has not approved the justice
department's motion to remove
the case altogether and he announced
instead that he would accept briefs
in the case from other lawyers and
and people arguing that the case should
stand i mean
like we said before michael flynn
pleaded guilty
and and that guilty plea was accepted by
the court
um and so so now there are there's
another judge involved i think
watergate prosecutors are involved and
sending motions as to
why why this case needs to stand
now some are asking questions about why
the judge isn't just accepting the
justice department's request to drop the
case
including fox news contributor and
former federal prosecutor andy mccarthy
who defends acting dna grinnell's
decision i think trump is tired
of having people tell him he can't
disclose things
so he took a guy who was loyal to him
but not an idiot
and who will you know not do anything to
to
overly prejudice uh american
intelligence but at the same time knows
the president
wants disclosure here and he's
disclosing and the first thing he tried
to do was get the justice department to
disclose it which
i suggest to me that he really doesn't
grinnell doesn't really understand how
the justice department works
you know the justice department doesn't
just disclose stuff to disclose stuff
they
they only disclose things when they have
a legal reason to do it like they did
with flynn last week when they filed
that motion
in court and i suppose that when
grinnell didn't get satisfaction from
the justice department
um he went to congress which you know
given that giving it to congress
yeah yeah sure and that's what they did
is that problematic though
i don't think so i mean this is
something that is a matter of great
public concern and it cannot possibly be
that it's okay for mueller for example
in a case where he doesn't charge the
president with obstruction
to publicize 200 pages of
instruction evidence that doesn't make
out an obstruction case
and now people are going to be upset
about disclosure or something that
people have been asking about
for three years and that actually goes
to the to a very important public
question
which is is the intelligence community
politicizing the very powerful
authorities we give them to protect the
country that's a that's a critical
question i can't think of is that what
happened do you do you believe looking
at the evidence
now that's what happened yeah no well i
believed it already i mean i wrote a
book about it i think that they
um and the re you know listen the reason
i
i i say that my thing is i'm i'm like a
national security guy that's what i
worked at the end of my
my last years in the justice department
and because i've had that experience
i know that we can't protect the country
without these counterintelligence tools
and what i've always been
worried about is if the public sees
that the intelligence community can't be
trusted to wield these towers without
politicizing them or using them
in capricious ways then there's going to
be a very strong argument as there is
now
on capitol hill that these towers need
to be either repealed
or rolled back in a significant way and
what i've always worried about is
if they do that we can't protect the
country
and i'm worried that we get to a point
where everybody concludes
that we can't trust these guys anymore
so that people like me
who have been arguing in favor of these
towers for you know years and years
no one's going to tune us out because i
can't look people in the eye and say
don't worry you can trust the
intelligence community to do the right
thing
i don't i don't know that we can say
that just for the simple sake of clarity
to end here
when you look at what happened what is
your
big concern what was done my big concern
is that the thing i always said in the
1990s could not happen has happened
which is that the intelligence and law
enforcement apparatus of the government
was exploited for political reasons by
the incumbent
administration first in an effort
to stop trump from becoming president i
don't think they tried that hard because
they didn't think there was any chance
that was actually going to happen
but then after trump won to hamstring
his ability to govern
uh and to make his administration and
his presidency as short
as it could be whether it was one term
or less
and i think they exploited
counterintelligence
powers in order to do a criminal
investigation against trump
that they didn't have a predicate for it
in other words they didn't have factual
evidence
that he had committed a crime and they
use counterintelligence because you can
it's very convenient it's all classified
and it's all
you know undercover and i think what
they tried to do was extend
the counterintelligence investigation
into the trump administration
hoping that eventually they would shake
out of the trees some
some crime that they could either
prosecute him for
or impeach him over and in the meantime
it was the death of a thousand cuts by
intelligence leaking
you know they're collecting all this
information and then they're putting out
the story about how trump is in cahoots
with russia so and that ought to
frighten people if they can do that to
the president
man they can do it anybody and if that
many people in the obama administration
are reading or listening to these
conversations and
asking for unmasking you know democrats
and folks on the other side would
will say and have said that's normal
they're allowed to do that they're
curious who is this person on this
other side of this phone call why can't
we know this this is important
what's what are you saying well what
we've heard here to for
is you have to you have to show more
than it's important
and the fact that you might be able on
any particular unmasking
to say that the standards for unmasking
are so
low that you know in other words if some
authorized intelligence person says we
need to understand
who this person is so that we can fully
exploit the intelligence value of this
piece of
intelligence they may be able to defend
every single or many at least of the
individual unmaskings
but if you look at this as a pattern
what it becomes is political spying
and i think you have to look at the
overarching fact pattern you can't just
look at
any individual unmasking andy mccarthy
thank you so much for your time it's my
pleasure
this is geraldo rivera with your fox
news commentary
coming up it's called the heroes act
the three trillion dollar coronavirus
economic stimulus bill proposed by house
democrats
there's more money for state and local
governments individual americans and
more money for food and unemployment aid
among other things
house speaker nancy pelosi we are
presenting a plan
to do what is necessary to deal with a
corona crisis
and make sure we can get the country
back to work
and school safely the top senate
republican mitch mcconnell says there's
a lot in the bill that has nothing to do
with coronavirus and calls the whole
thing
an unserious product from an unserious
house majority that has spent months
dealing itself out of the crisis and he
says it's not going anywhere
i think uh we're nowhere in terms of
actually passing a new stimulus and you
have
uh the head of the federal reserve
jerome powell saying we need more
stimulus chris wallace is the host of
fox news sunday
this economic situation is going to be
worse and last
longer and and it appears that politics
you know one of the things that i was
really impressed with is the situation
was so
dire that they were able to pass these
last three and a half stimulus bills
uh basically unanimously
bipartisan uh because people you know we
don't have time to
mess around uh evidently now they think
we do have time to mess around
and you're right the the house
democrats the majority there are pushing
a bill which will make a statement but
doesn't have a chance of passing
and republicans are saying let's wait
and see
uh and in the meantime there are a lot
of businesses there are a lot of states
there are a lot of individuals
in a lot of trouble and i don't think
we're going to see a a
a fourth uh phase four
bill passed probably until june right
and not in time for some of these
businesses to stay afloat i have a
friend who was arguing well jesus christ
you can't just keep printing money no
actually you literally can
and i'm not an economist but
you have to find the point where not
doing it is going to cost you more in
the long run
well that's right and and here you have
jerome powell who
uh is not you know just uh let's throw
money into the wind the head of the
federal reserve
as president trump called him this week
his most improved player
uh and he's saying we need more stimulus
and and you know look everybody hates it
and we were talking about trillions and
trillions of dollars i mean you know we
were
so upset about the debt and now it's
just been
blown out it's going to be in you know
over
26 28 trillion dollars uh
but at certain times in times of war and
it appears in a time of a a
scorching pandemic you've got to take
desperate measures
anthony fauci this week told americans
including the president something a lot
of us
you know don't want to hear that getting
through this is not going to be easy and
it's not going to be fast
but he also makes the point that you and
i have touched on that the health
concerns are the economic concerns if
you don't do this right you're going to
risk worse economic consequences
absolutely and and look again nobody and
and fauci says it nobody appointed him
god no
you know as as rand paul said he's not
the be all and end all and he said some
things in this
uh that turned out to be wrong he was
kind of downplaying the risk back in
february
um having said that you know you have to
listen i'm not saying that he's the only
person you listen to but you do have to
listen
to two experts and if you've got a guy
who has been the head of infectious
disease for
uh the last what 35 years
uh you know he i think he at least
listened to him
and and you know and as as we've said
both of us have said before you can't
spin the virus you can't say
well you know it's been long enough uh
well
the virus gets a vote and if the virus
says it hasn't been long enough then you
gotta
do it now it may well be that uh
you know there are two sides to this
story i mean i remember when
uh brian kemp the governor of georgia
started to open up georgia
i was very questioning of it
so was donald trump i remember donald
trump calling him out in really sharp
terms
uh from the white house briefing room
and it turns out
georgia has not had a huge spike in
cases there they haven't gone down
but they're kind of plateaued uh and you
know it hasn't been the disaster a lot
of people predicted so
you know nobody's right necessarily all
you can do is you make your best
judgment about how to proceed
i mean i've been reading a lot this week
uh about
how we're going to move forward without
without these shutdowns and i agree that
some of them just aren't helping for
example it seems pretty difficult to be
infected just by passing contact or
brief contact especially if you're
outside
now then if you open the beaches you
either have to enforce or trust people
to take their own precautions
well i know and and the problem though
is you see some of these pictures
of uh i mean for instance yesterday
the uh wednesday i guess it was the uh
state supreme court in wisconsin just
basically throughout the stay-at-home
order
uh from the governor tony evers and then
i see
pictures where people are in the bars
without mass no social distancing up
close to each other
well they're idiots i mean nobody said
that that was the right thing to do
i could understand their relief and
their sense of you know they've gotten
out of jail
but uh you know when you say trust
people to do the right thing
a lot of people won't remember when
gavin newsom opened up the beaches
in uh in california and you know they're
clearly
a beach is a reasonably safe place if
you keep your distance
and there were huge crowds of people
where they weren't uh
distancing at all so i mean i i clearly
there are some cases
you know as somebody said how can it be
okay in a golf course a golf
course but not on a tennis court so you
know i think some of the things probably
have gone too far but you also do need
people
to uh to observe the rules and sometimes
people don't
the people that want to open everything
up and want to go to bars they talk
they're talking about their freedom well
there's freedom too and there's freedom
from they want the freedom to
go to a bar people who don't want to go
to that bar want the freedom from
getting sick well that's right
and you know in is i guess i forget
the exact line but it's basically like
your freedom
and you know the freedom of your fist
ends at the point of my chin
which is you can swing your fist all you
want until it hits me in the face and
then it's assault
and you know you can go do a lot of
things
but at the point that you now have
gotten the virus
or potentially gotten the virus and then
you come in contact with me and spread
it to me
uh you know that's where my freedom
starts and
and so these are really complicated
issues and
frankly they become more complicated as
things become a little better
uh a couple of polls real quick um
i read one from mommy's university i
thought was interesting that among
people who
disliked both president trump and
hillary clinton last time
he won a large majority of those votes
people said all right well we'll go with
the devil we don't know
uh that's flipped among trump and
clinton haters now
most of them say we've seen enough and
now we'll go for bite so
the president either either has to run
on his record or gets to run on his
record depending on how you see it
yeah um well i mean that's going to be i
think one of the really key questions
and a lot of it depends on where the
pandemic is where the economic downturn
is
uh in the fall if it's if it's
bad then i think that uh
it's going to be a referendum on trump
if it's pretty good
then i think actually it ends up being
in that plus for the president and
people are you know people are fair even
if there's a
a a pandemic going on and let's say
unemployment is
10 uh you know as opposed to my guess is
at the end of may it's going to be over
20
people are fair and are going to
understand that's not president trump's
fault that you know he was presented
with something
that that nobody could have prevented
maybe you could have handled better
maybe not
uh but i mean that the key for president
trump
is to turn this not into a referendum on
him but into
a choice election is it you know it's
not
trump versus trump or trump versus you
know how it should have been handled
better
it's trump versus biden because you know
let's be honest biden is not
the strongest candidate in the world and
you know every time you see him i mean
just this
week when he was on good morning america
and he was asked about
uh the investigation of michael flynn
general flynn and he said i don't know
anything about it and then
stephanopoulos said well you were in a
meeting anyone oh i thought you said the
prosecution of him not the
investigation you know which certainly
looks like he was trying to
hide the ball so you know he every time
he comes out he has a tendency i won't
say every time
he has a tendency to to raise an issue
raise an eyebrow
disappoint we talked a couple weeks ago
about um sports not being around
and how uh you actually mentioned that
it would be weird watching a baseball
game
say without any crowd noise now joe buck
from the mother ship over at fox
says that there they are in fact when
nfl games start without crowds they're
going to pump in crowd noise and they
might even actually put
cgi fans in the seats just to replicate
the experience i'm okay
i haven't heard that but you know i'm
all for it i look you know
i don't like staging of news and i don't
like staging of uh
uh you know making things up but sports
is a little bit different
and if you've got crowd noise uh
you know it makes it a more pleasurable
experience and i don't think it's it's
uh
it's gonna offend people says i you know
i
when i hear about piping and noise i
just it's out of the blue but people may
be a little bit interested so
the masters is one of my favorite tv
sports events and
you know every year one of the things
that that cbs does
is they put you know they have
microphones so you can hear the birds
tweeting in the
early spring in augusta georgia well
somebody
was such a purist that they heard a i
don't know a blue jay whipper will as
i'm making it up
and and called in and said that's fake
because there are no blue jay
whipperwheels
in augusta georgia in april and cbs had
to own up and in fact they had typed in
fake bird chirping noises not knowing
any better
and of course some purists had just
called them out on it so
i hope that you know i hope that if fox
does it they don't put
baseball noise over a baseball game or
something like that so keep it keep it
at least in the same sport
all right chris you've got a new book
coming out uh we'll talk about that in a
couple weeks it gets as it gets closer
just as a tease
uh chris wallace host of fox news sunday
thanks again
you bet thank you chris
[Music]
from the fox news podcast network
download and listen to the untold story
with martha mccallum the host of the
story on fox news channel sits down with
major newsmakers each week to get their
untold story subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
gifts can come from the most unexpected
places
and the ones money can't buy are
oftentimes the ones that mean the most
that's the kind of gift brad meltzer
told me about
he's a new york times best-selling
author and has written fiction and
non-fiction books for adults
but he's also written kids books
specifically the i
am series they focus on a different
historical character
i am neil armstrong i am abraham lincoln
i am harriet tubman i am lucille ball
you get the picture
so when i asked him to share some good
news with me he told me a story that has
to do with a reaction
to one of those books so those who know
that we do children's books we've done i
am albert einstein and we did i am
albert einstein because we wanted to
give
kids a lesson about being different the
book open's ever been called weird
never been called different and a few
years back we got a letter from
a mother who said that she read that
book with her son who was on
on the autistic spectrum who was weird
and who was different
but was told it's you know it's
beautiful to be different
and she thanked me because her she told
me her son had just passed away
the most horrible horrors for a parent
and she wanted to thank me because
reading
i am albert einstein with her son was
the last
great fun moment they actually had
together before he died
so of course we tracked down the story
we sent
books to her son's her classroom so we
could honor him
and she walked into the classroom and
everyone had the book signed in honor of
her
her son who had died but here's the part
that blew me away
is just recently i got another letter
from this woman
and she said to me a few years later
brad you know i was pregnant because she
had told me that
but i want to announce the birth of our
new son and we name them
after two of our heroes one of them his
first name is finn after finn in star
wars
she said but i want you to meet young
finn bradley
and of all the things we've done with
the ordinary people change the world
series
i love that people can read i am abraham
lincoln or i am amelia earhart or i am
walt disney
but that this woman named her new son
after me doing these books it was
probably one of the greatest gifts
that anyone has ever given me and i
never realized that these books would be
a gift to myself as well
you never know where good news will come
from brad meltzer's newest book is a
non-fiction work called the lincoln
conspiracy the secret plot to kill
america's 16th president and why it
failed
and is out now tanya j powers fox news
it's time for your fox news commentary
geraldo
rivera what's on your mind you know you
haven't heard much of lately
fear that our grocery shelves would be
empty
you remember what it was like in early
march
when people began hoarding when there
was real fear that the
supply chain had broken down
that crops weren't being picked they
weren't being transported
to stores where they could be
distributed to a hungry public
that fear now has largely dissipated
hasn't it
you know what else you haven't heard
much of lately
rage rage directed at the millions of
undocumented immigrants among us
you know why because among the heroes of
the corona pandemic
are millions of those undocumented
agricultural workers who have kept us
fed
and they have done that job as they have
for decades indeed for generations
with the fear looming over them that the
migrant
the man would come and deport them
do you know one of the secrets that has
been
revealed during this pandemic
at the very least 75 percent
of the people who harvest america's food
are here without proper documentation
they are
in the pejorative illegal aliens
yet they come they work
picking our fruits and vegetables
processing the poultry
packing the meat and feeding us
i have in my hand a memo
from no less an agency than the
department of homeland security
the memo says guidance on the essential
critical
infrastructure workforce quoting
from christopher krebs he's director of
cyber security
and infrastructure security quote
if you work in a critical infrastructure
industry
as defined by the department of homeland
security such as health care services
and pharmaceutical and food supply you
have a special responsibility
to maintain your normal work schedule
that has been interpreted to mean that
the people who are here
tilling our fields and working in our
food supply
will not be harassed by the dhs
operatives who will finally focus on
what i have been urging for years
have these agents not go after juan and
maria
let the agencies go after the
drug dealers the felons
the gang bangers let them go after the
people who are a threat
to america not to the people who feed us
not to the people but for whom we would
have gone hungry
remember millions of americans
would have been hungry but for the
efforts
of these calloused hands
and to those who say wait a second
you can't give millions of undocumented
agricultural workers a pass
what about all these unemployed
americans
the unemployed americans ladies and
gentlemen
have rejected they have shunned these
hard jobs these workers are essential
because there are not
americans to fill these jobs even in
these desperate times
they are heroes of the corona pandemic
they deserve a whole new look
they deserve compassion
and our thanks i'm gerald rivera
reporting
fox news
[Music]
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion
you trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes